[Music]
three friend nudes news send them send
foods submitted by come to New Zealand
oh I'd love to I want to be the girl Oh
Tiger sounds like a New Zealand name
Panama its Mari oh there it is okay Wow
perfect okay yeah he should go yeah my
people his name roots Maori oh there's
there's part of it in there now why wait
what do you ever like give us special
like a like affinity to merit the Maori
culture Maori in your blood no I don't
what I have an affinity towards it she's
fake as [ __ ] so you have a Chinese
tattoo on your arm
no David did you but for Polynesians
she doesn't even Chinese tattoos you
know Chinese dick insider that's like
five Chinese people that's racist all
right Facebook is asking people to send
their own nudes in an effort to stop
revenge porn what what that's genius
revenge porn is the stuff where they
it's like an ex girlfriend or boyfriend
and then you post it on like Tumblr or
WeChat or where you say explain revenge
porn
okay so revenge porn is like let's say
we're dating you send me a dick pic and
then we break up and then I'm like I'm
gonna show everyone films dick and then
just send it up it's revenge porn good
though are they like cute asking for a
friend
so if they like it's a good stuff though
people are probably embarrassed by it
mmm yeah but you would only bug but you
end up only sent them good stuff right
so they would only have good photos
David and Mariel were having sex
Mariel wanted to record a video of it
and then David's in a ball gag in a
diaper and yeah like Angel winks and
that's the was like how did you see this
you probably don't want that to go
public or not even that like it's just
some normal [ __ ] like tip said it's just
your private like it like you don't walk
around naked for a reason you know what
I mean because the laws allow me well
not you but like most people like you
don't walk around naked cuz it's just
you're not comfortable so yeah Thank You
private right I said called your
privates I don't mind private what if
it's like hey senator I'm proud of that
well then it's not revenge it versus
like then you get a reality TV show
become famous exactly look at it then
you become Ray J and Kim Kardashian and
then your life is great actually right
have you ever been invited to a wedding
of a girl that you begged no no okay
yeah they invited you to their wedding
they she wanted me to be the officiant
Oh funny and then you see all the
stories like I know you're getting
yourself into problems you know she's
not even an excellent after I did it for
you right and I'm I just I do that
because number one we have rapport I've
been around you for six years like it's
it's easy for me to do it for you guys
yeah I mean so this girl like I dated
her two years or a year before Marriott
right she cool yeah and I might word
we're like lightweight friends right
we're don't we don't keep in contact all
the time but she goes yo so I saw that
you did it for your friends is like
we're looking for a fish if we don't
want it to be religious so can you I'm
like I saw you naked yeah and I was like
you does your does your a husband-to-be
know that you and I used to date no but
he'll be fine with it no no I know so I
told her I was like you should ask him
first yeah which I don't even suggest in
the first place because it's gonna be an
automatic no so you want an argument I
saw you naked and you want me to do your
what it's not really I saw you naked
like like in high school yeah it was
like not that long it's too fresh yeah
like it's like I can see you naked now
yeah if you [ __ ] like 15 years ago but
since then it's been platonic you have
no desires to put it back in then that's
very different I think even still
and if someone asked a random question
who [ __ ] there's gonna be two guys
raising it
very clever question and wedding
washroom wait what's who asks that
[Music]
priest but I'm all really I have friends
and and I [ __ ] but where I have no
desire to put it back in or get my dick
anywhere near that the vicinity because
it's morphed into something else and I
wouldn't mind going to their wedding you
know we invited to our wedding cuz I'm
like we're cool now like that because
that's also different to you because you
have a son with that person for sure
that's why there's a reason but then
after I thought about it I'm like hmm
but you know that's one thing like if I
was up there what am I supposed to say
hey does she do things for you this you
know what's your power you know it's too
fresh it's too fresh and it's so hot I
just like wait I don't think we could be
friends after that because it's just so
what were you trying to gain from this
yeah just so uncomfortable right now
yeah because David to me doesn't have a
dick officiate you're just anything
about sex and David you just like I
don't have sex you don't think anybody
has a dick though uh any of my friends
yes like that son of a dick and ho-ho I
think in Kate Malin from a [ __ ]
storks mouth Draca at her front door she
had no she she didn't know what else to
do is she's like because she's so kind
she took care of this stork child I'm
the opposite everybody got a dick all my
all my female friends got a dick you got
a dick and you got a dick I think and
they're all bigger than yours massive
it's grotesque bikinis I'm like where's
your bulge at because I'm expecting that
you have a dick
all right that's a story yeah how do we
even get into this because a revenge
porn it's still in the same vicinity of
the
all right so Facebook is helping to
combat the rise of a wrench porn online
by asking its users to send their own
naked photos that they believe have been
does a spreading those stupid isn't the
reason why are you doing it down oh they
get the photo match oh I thought it was
like one of those like hashtag me two
things worse I I'm I'm proud of my junk
so so go ahead that's what I was
thinking this is they're piloting this
program in Australia and so they've
teamed up with the Australian
Government's East Safety Division oh my
god
they want to do face recognition for
your dick yes recognition that different
oh they're all so different a person
that's worried that their intimate
photos have been shared online they fill
up this form on the e-safety
commissioner's website then the user
sends the photos that they think that
are being spread to themselves you know
on facebook Messenger and then while
that's happening the e-safety
commissioner's office then notifies
facebook of the person submission and
then the facebook community team they
use the image matching ecology and they
prevent the image from being uploaded or
shared online so the image matching
technology is automatic so it kind of
turns the photo into like a hashtag so
then immediately once the site
recognizes that the photo is on the site
it immediately takes it down and it
notifies the user that they need they
should delete that image because it's
they should go to jail that seems like a
lot of effort and resources being used
to just like get dicks off the website
unless it this does this happen that
much why is it just is it you said
Australia is it just Australia
highlighting it there did it we didn't
we do an article a JK where there was
like either a venezuelan or Colombian or
Argentinean female cop that took down a
drug lord and then they they found nude
photos of her about the cop that took
him down and then spread it everywhere
oh maybe I was just masturbating
five would actually work but don't you
need someone sorting all the photos
that's what I'm saying so someone is
there like lucky em it's gonna be the
most common in the whole entire Facebook
coalition also so pretty much where does
it start it turns the image to a series
of numbers how do you how do you prevent
fraud so for example let's say me and
Phil we took a photo right and it's a
bad angle of me and I was telling that
they'll don't [ __ ] post it and he
posted it anyways and I'm like how can I
[ __ ] take this photo down I know I'll
utilize the Facebook [ __ ] [ __ ] porn
revenge thing and I'll report so that
photo isn't even actual revenge porn but
I'm just utilizing that system as a loop
on I upload it so you still have to have
someone that's going yep that's revenge
porn
well no it'll just be like YouTube
Content ID where it's like it can just
see the numbers yeah like the the binary
whatever and then just realize oh this
match is something that's been reported
and your afford will get taken down but
then you're gonna appeal it so what
could you wait but that's not even
revenge porn so you're gonna appeal it
now somewhat actual human has to go back
maybe someone yeah maybe at some one
person then like [ __ ] Millie but then
but then I guess they would have to get
to that point like if it was really like
a dick and someone was someone from
Facebook said hey someone reported that
this is not a dick pic that you're
supposed to be posting it why am I
really gonna be like no I'm supposed to
like like you know like I want to appeal
this like please keep my dick pic up
depends on how much you like that photo
right well how much revenge I want it's
so interesting when I see so there's
this girl that I follow on Instagram her
name is MIA King
so I actually fault her because I
thought she was a Muay Thai fighter
right I should I [ __ ] dope she's like
half Korean half half white but she was
like some kind of bug like Instagram not
in sorry that's offensive to I guess but
vogue Sports Illustrated I believe so if
she's a professional model right but
she's uh I thought she was just a
fighter but she's actually a vogue like
models take a body-positive model but
even with her she you know she does the
thing on her on her [ __ ] [ __ ] where
she's like naked and doing it I'm like
what are you what do you get what does a
girl get from that when they do that
like what
the positive like what is that what is
the endorphins that they get from taking
a video of themselves and doing this you
know with the [ __ ] they look good
they feel good that they look like a
filling themselves and then then people
start complimenting and it's like okay
cool you're just validating that I look
good or if she's a real if she's a real
model she's probably just creating a
part or that's their product in a sense
like it yet at the end of the day like
yeah if if the product yeah like if if
you are essentially a product your looks
or your sexuality even like it's less
part of the part because it's so weird
because I followed her for something
else when I see that I'm just interested
I'm like right David right yeah oh she's
doing all this abductor stuff that's not
what I want
there's the other girls that I just
followed specifically for the looks for
her I actually grabbed her thing so I
could send over to Muriel because she
actually likes kickboxing so if it's
like stay in your lane girl don't be
sexy I wanted you just yeah what the
[ __ ] you shaving your legs is she doing
come on man what is this she's pretty
dope though follow she's dope she's in
that toilet right now notice notice him
senpai I know that notice yes Lee just
want her to kick me in the face I don't
know what that feels like I can help
no but that if you kick me in the face
they want to give me a boner so I want
her to [ __ ] I want her to [ __ ] me up
while she's naked what's so wrong about
that I don't understand that's fine
that's totally allowed and that and then
that's that goes back to the video that
Bart found of you in the ball gag and
they know how you found out about that
[ __ ] dude I spy
[Music]
Oh